hey everybody movie retrospective time
yeah here is a movie that i am amazed
that tom has never seen i've never seen
this one i had never seen never seen it
uh
it's just amazing to me it's amazing to
me that you have never seen it fight
club is not a good movie
fight club is a [ __ ] great movie well
of course it is everybody knows that
i've been hearing about it you know off
and on for a long time but i never had a
chance to see it just never got around
to it and it was not what i thought it
was
it's not what i expected it was [ __ ]
pretty pretty cool deep
weird twists and [ __ ] yeah and they
called a lot of stuff right about humans
and human nature and i didn't see it
coming as it was starting to unfold it
was badass
very badass
it's interesting because uh yeah so even
though the first two roles of fight club
are you not supposed to talk about fight
club we're talking about fight club yeah
so this is uh came out in 1999 obviously
directed by the awesome david fincher
yeah uh who has made so many good movies
you guys [ __ ] zodiac seven
uh he was he worked on mind hunter the
tv series he did gone girl
he just he's done like so many [ __ ]
classic movies
and uh this is definitely one of them
now this was based on the novel by chuck
palahniuk uh who this was his first
novel i think
um i've read it a long time ago i think
the novel came out in 1996.
i don't know this guy's background
but whatever influenced him he was right
on about
military cults and what what what what
what what a warrior cult is that's what
this is about and you know
if you know if you're not
you're not a regular to the show you
know i've had a good military career and
a paramilitary career
working for law enforcement type stuff
in support
roles but
coming out of the 101st airborne
division first 327 recon first 506
infantry up on the dmz in korea [ __ ]
some operations in the middle east
i'm very familiar with warrior cults the
army is a huge warrior cult and i was
like out of some of the cultist of the
cult cult cult warrior cults just
[ __ ] google one
backslash 327 recon platoon
and we're in there man [ __ ] hell yeah
this is what a warrior cult is and i
didn't see this movie coming it started
slowly and then i realized that as the
story unfolds all this shit's happening
to serve a bigger purpose
and things aren't as they seem you at
the end you're like oh okay all right i
don't know if i want i guess we can
spoil the twist eventually everybody has
seen this movie
and everybody knows what the twist is
yeah this dude's mentor that's [ __ ]
teaching him to be a badass
you find out that it's his alter ego
that he's talking to himself kind of
like something out of venom
he's very much like you know you [ __ ]
you know
he's got this inner demon that [ __ ]
drives him to [ __ ] more and more
higher and higher heights
you know in terms of [ __ ]
physical performance and
combat effectiveness you know to destroy
a bunch of [ __ ] banks you know it's
it's terrorism basically economic
terrorism
and he's [ __ ] created a huge warrior
cult to support him and it just happened
without him knowing that he did he
thought this other guy did it it's
badass that's good it's good flick well
there have been like a batman villain
kinda yeah he's kinda like a bad bad
film it's interesting because i mean
there have been dissertations written on
this movie okay this is one of those i
mean this is one of those movies
that and you see this a lot with these
kind of uh movies that become like huge
cultural phenomenons like later on when
this came out in 1999
um it didn't do all that well like it
did okay but not as well and the studio
executives didn't really like it i don't
think they knew how to market it
um in 1999 they so i think that the
marketing you know what i can remember
of it it kind of focused just more on
the fighting but that's not really what
the movie is about
uh and i don't really think that they
knew how to approach it and um so it i
don't so i don't know if it was just the
marketing or just people weren't ready
for it at the time or
people didn't get it or i'm not really
sure like what the problem was but when
it came out in the theaters it didn't do
all that well um it kind of got you know
a mixed cul uh critical response people
didn't get it i don't think yeah it
might have been that but then like when
it came out on dvd and stuff like that
it started picking up like a massive
cult following in a lot of the same way
that stuff like you know if like office
space or idiocracy or something like
that where you know it didn't really do
that well in the theater but then like
when people started seeing it there was
like a huge word of mouth thing and soon
like i said everybody
that's why i was amazed that you had
never seen fight club because it it's
it's so
penetrated into american culture that um
i'm always like surprised when people
haven't seen it yeah uh just because
well as you would think that well fight
clubs just about some dudes fighting in
a club no not really it's not that's not
really what it's about yeah
i mean there that is in there it is it
is violent and stuff like that but
that's not really what it's about it's
about this dude who's got a split
personality
and his i guess you could say his dark
side alter ego
is driving him
to do all this stuff and
one of the things that they do is that
he's bringing people into this warrior
cult and he's toughening them all up he
even recruits from all these self-help
groups and everything
but he's doing it subconsciously kind of
under the direction of this
higher ego that he has a superego
and this super ego is like better than
him better looking than him more funny
more sexually [ __ ] uh uh aggressive
he's everything he wishes to be he
thinks it's his sensei basically this or
his
platoon sergeant or his friend or
something
no it's him he doesn't realize it you
know
but uh he builds a damn warrior cult out
of this [ __ ] underground fighting
club it has a bigger purpose it's just
to get them to
teach them
they they slowly turn into a damn
warrior cult
where they're honoring the fallen dead
and [ __ ] doing all kinds of stuff
and and they're ready to sacrifice their
lives for a bigger cause
it's a lot like kind of some of the some
of the batman villains
are being shown as but this one explains
how you do it it's almost like a how-to
manual
and having personal experience
everything shown in this movie would
work that's the way people are
under those conditions
you just have to find the right ones
yeah i kind of feel like the interesting
thing and like i said there are several
different i guess interpretations of
this movie if you really want to go i
don't know if interpretations
uh are there because i think it's pretty
straightforward but i mean there are
different like angles you can come at it
you know
um you know a lot of people have said i
think a lot of people resonated with the
first half of the movie as a critique of
capitalism
uh you know or this kind of mindless
consumerism is probably the better yeah
empty consumerism don't have any
warriors spirit to them no spirit they
just buy [ __ ] and then they die they're
forgotten that's what this is a very
niche of rising out of the morass is
what is what they're talking about
escaping the wheel of suffering that's
and i mean it's a very generation x
movie um which chuck pollaniak is
generation x brad pitt is as well i
think um so it's getting into that hole
and i think even brad pitt has a line in
the movie where he calls this the middle
children of history like we didn't have
a war we didn't have anything like no
cause to fight for and now it's just
like this empty consumerism yeah so the
narrator played by uh edward norton who
is never given a name he doesn't
actually have a name
uh through the first half of the movie
he's just
you know he goes by different uh you
know weird names like when he goes to
the different groups and stuff but he
doesn't have an actual name yeah if the
movie is is a critique of capitalism i'm
going to agree with that it is a
critique critique of capitalism but not
as an economic system more as a
spiritual system
capitalism has given giving you the
comforts
comforts that you need to become weak
you have to strip those away so you
become harder
that's what they're talking about
capitalism has made you weak and
comfortable seeking pleasure that's
exactly what that's part of the thing
because that's what's sweet memory
strips
out of those people it gets them to
enjoy pain and suffering to make them
stronger that's that which does not kill
you makes you stronger very niching idea
that's but yeah so it is that's part of
it
but it's also
self-actualization through
through this warrior cult
destroying enemies
and you know and having your ideology
take over the other ideologies to become
dominant to the achievement of dominance
in the end that's what that's how i and
that's how i interpreted it even though
it was there was a mental illness there
yeah no well okay so how i interpreted
the movie um you know like i said i kind
of feel like most people know
what happens in this movie um
you know you have narrator played by
edward norton he uh has this sort of
empty existence he has an office job
that he hates uh and he can't really uh
you know he just kind of decorates his
apartment with all this ikea furniture
and he can't really
feel anything
um so he's kind of and he's suffering
from insomnia and so he starts going to
these self-help groups of diseases that
he doesn't have like testicular cancer
and things like that
uh because he finds that that's the only
way he can get any sleep by like
releasing some emotions because like i
said he's kind of become an emotionless
sort of drone in our consumer society or
whatever now a catalyzing uh event
happens when he meets marla played by
helena bonham carter who is doing
essentially the same [ __ ] that he's
doing like being a tourist to all of
these groups but she's much more like
ballsy and brass you know out front
about it and the cute young goth girl
you got goth type chick in this stage in
her career
she's what maybe 30. i have that i have
no idea okay
um but yeah so she's like a lot more
unapologetic about it
and she clearly has some mental problems
as well but they kind of have a
connection but he gets pissed off about
it because he's like well you're here
and you're like proud of being like she
goes to testicular cancer groups which
obviously she doesn't have uh you know
what i mean and she just like daring
people to call her out on it and nobody
does
so uh so edward norton is like well i
can't you know get into the the
emotional release of these groups if
you're here because i know that you're
faking so they have to come up with this
this some kind of thing where you know
we'll all go on these days and you go on
these days and blah blah now shortly
after he meets her
which is significant timing
uh he supposedly meets tyler durden
played by brad pitt on an airplane now
tyler durden says that he's a soap
salesman
and uh that he's he basically gives a
little bit of a philosophical but yeah
like he's everything that edward norton
i guess wishes he was you know he's very
handsome he's very uh you know outgoing
he's very you know like you said like
sexually aggressively he's [ __ ] brad
pitt right yeah um you know and and he
also kind of tends toward a sort of like
hey man what's like free chaotic yeah
kind of energy yeah i also gotta say
brad pitt is [ __ ] in great [ __ ]
physical condition in this in in this
movie he's [ __ ] at his tip top
well they train that's cut man they
trained both brad pitt and edward norton
in like all mixed martial arts they did
all that kind of stuff like before they
did this brad looks [ __ ] cut as [ __ ]
in this he does look really good in this
movie yeah
um but you know and and they did do even
though the fight scenes were
choreographed they said that they
actually did say hey just like wail on
the people you know because they wanted
it to look as realistic as possible
so he meets tyler durden and tyler
durden over it's interesting because at
first
um it seems like tyler durden is like
helping out because he's just kind of
like well you know you're too buttoned
up or you're too worried about your
consumerists whatever they end up living
together after edward norton's apartment
mysteriously explodes
so he ends up living in this ramshackle
old house with tyler durden and there
kind of becomes like a love triangle
thing between the two of them and marla
you know where tyler durden is just like
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of marla and you
know and like the narrator is getting
all pissed off about it and everything
[ __ ] all beating down in this [ __ ]
bomb that old [ __ ] house and he's
[ __ ] banging away on this chick
he likes you know what i mean and it's
funny she comes down you know [ __ ]
and then she's trying to talk to him and
[ __ ] he's what do you he kind of
turns on
and [ __ ] his boys keep to get her out
of here get her out here and he don't
tell him don't don't even you know don't
talk to her about me that kind of [ __ ]
is another thing and he's got to kick
her out which is funny because you don't
real you don't know it at the time you
watch the movies that from her point of
view she doesn't see two dudes she sees
one
the other guy's telling him to kick her
out and he's still all cucked out he
cucked out over himself
well i mean from her point of view he
just seems like psycho
yeah right from his point of view
there's another dude in the house
yeah
but that's what yeah and like i said i
think that it was really good like the
way it was set up yeah because it
actually does seem like there's two
people yeah but knowing the twist when
you go back and watch it again the
second time it will become very clear to
you that when edward norton and brad
pitt are having discussions it's usually
not in front of other people or there's
always some kind of
uh you know plausible deniability as to
how that dude is not there he's got that
same thing that [ __ ] jack torrance
and [ __ ] venom and [ __ ] i have
there's somebody else talking to you
he's got that same thing yeah but but to
everyone else's point of view it just
looks like he's either punching himself
in the face or he's talking to himself
or something like that because he sees
another one i knew something was up
because there's a couple times in the
movie where he turns and looks at
something you can see the flash of a
person standing yeah there are single
frames of brad pitt yeah prior to his
introduction to the film i believe there
are four of them yeah um because and
that ties back to
one of uh one of tyler's things is one
of his you know agent of chaos type
things is that he likes to take a single
frame of porn and splice it into like a
family movie like when all the kids are
there so it's like they're and so you
know edward norton even turns to the
camera and says you know they don't know
they saw it but they saw it yeah and
interesting at the yeah so there's like
single frame flashes of tyler if you if
you didn't notice and there's also right
before the end credits i think there's
also a single frame of porn i think it's
like a flaccid dick or something yeah
okay that you can see like right before
they start when i saw a couple of those
flashes in the movie i realized that
either something's not right with the
with the reality we're being shown yeah
that's a hint that he's not a real
person right and it's like i said it's
it's instructive that tyler durden
doesn't appear in edward norton's life
until after he meets marla because the
thing about edward norton's character is
that he has emotionally shut off right
and so he is unable to deal with
his feelings toward marla
and uh he feels perhaps inadequate or
you know whatever it is so he so that's
kind of like the catalyzing agent for
him to like come out with this
other personality that has all these
things that that he wants to be or that
he or that he perceives that she wants
you know what i mean so that's kind of
where all of that is coming from
now after a time though
uh tyler starts getting a little bit out
of edward norton's control in the sense
that edward norton is still having this
really bad insomnia which is not
insomnia because it's just he's going
and doing tyler durden [ __ ] while he's
supposed to be sleeping so he's not
actually sleeping even though he thinks
that he is
uh so tyler durden is essentially
uh he starts out kind of small just
doing kind of like funny [ __ ] like oh
let's go and blockbuster and erase all
the videotapes um you know with the big
magnet you know just little stupid [ __ ]
like that or those uh those funny ass uh
things they put in the airplanes with
like all the people going ah like with
the flames like killing everybody
because you know there was a scene
of them like talking about [ __ ] on the
airplanes and the little safety cards so
doing [ __ ] like that but as the movie
goes on the [ __ ] slowly starts to ramp
up and ramp up
to a point where uh brad pitt has
pretty much recruited like an army
and is doing like some
terrorist [ __ ] yeah uh
it seems pointless it's not political
yeah it's well the thing about it is
that
if you know in aggregate he's he's
supposed to be i guess he's kind of like
the joker he's like an agent of chaos
yep i mean he's not a good guy obviously
but you can understand
how someone would
would think of it because yeah everybody
can relate to like having a shitty job
or having a shitty boss or having like
feeling like you don't have any purpose
in life or feeling like disconnected
from your emotions everybody can
uh deal with that you know or everybody
can uh relate to that
you saying that he was like the joker is
probably why i thought that it was he
was like a batman villain yeah because
he does the same thing that the joker
does the joker burned a whole pile of
money he didn't need the money yeah he
had nothing to do with it that's what
he's doing he's he's destroying a whole
block of [ __ ] office buildings
because he doesn't need money
he's beyond that
money and working [ __ ] jobs made him
[ __ ] immune to it he didn't give [ __ ]
he was more about just
self growth and accurate you know
actualization and
achieving dominance over a system that
he saw that was oppressing his natural
humanistic
urges i guess would be a good way to put
it
but the irony of the film is
that
as the uh as the
terroristic activities get more and more
elaborate and as he actually has gotten
to a point where he's formed essentially
a paramilitary unit yeah um the the
irony of it is that he has become the
very thing that he was rebelling against
at the beginning what's the cycle right
um at the beginning he was just like you
know i don't even have a name it's like
i'm just this nameless drone that does
whatever i'm told we all do whatever
we're told and then as but as the movie
goes on you know this he becomes that he
becomes that because obviously you know
the paramilitary group that he forms
they all wear the same thing they always
do exactly what they're told without
being questioned none of them have names
until you know after they die
and things like that so like i said
that's kind of the irony of the whole uh
film and that's kind of one thing that
because i feel like when this first came
out it seemed like it was really popular
with like teenagers
um and i think that they related like i
said to the sort of like
anti-consumerist type of thing which is
in the movie
but i don't know if they failed to
realize that
you know in doing this quote unquote
chaotic
sort of thing like he ended up pretty
much in the exact same place that he
started i guess how some people might
see that as irony to me i just see it as
a
as as the system that that's how it is
it's a cycle
well right i know that but i'm just
saying that ironic in the sense that i
don't know if if original audiences
might have picked up on that or maybe a
younger audience
it goes back to nietzsche everything
everything that exists imposes on
something else there's no way not to
impose
um
animals uh feed on other animals men
feed on the animals the animals feed on
the grass the grass competes with each
other
the grass are competing each other for
nutrients and even light even inanimate
objects [ __ ] over other inanimate
objects by occupying space that another
object could occupy
there is no way to exist without
dominating so it's him getting into the
system and taking the role of the thing
that was of the system that was
oppressing him it's just part of it and
replacing it to achieve dominance but
that's never forever he ends up being
replaced because eventually time time
get you can't win forever but that's
just the the cycle
that's that's how i interpret it
and honestly the end of the movie is a
little bit different than the end of the
book i think in the end of the book um
the narrator
ends up in like after he realizes that
tyler durden is a you know projection of
his id if you were whatever if you want
to call it
combined um you know after he realized
that i think he ends up in in an asylum
yeah but at the end of the movie
um he actually starts to fight back
against uh tyler durden's you know
philosophy if you want to call it that
just because he realizes
this is going the same way that
you know what i was fighting against
from the beginning you know uh and he
kind of finds his humanity again in the
sense that he's actually able to care
about uh robert [ __ ] tits paulson when
he gets killed which is meatloaf uh when
he gets killed he actually cares about
that he cares about the woman in the
cancer group uh chloe and he actually
like asked marla and is able to tell
marla that he really likes her and he
cares better he doesn't want anything to
happen to her so it seems that at the
end even though all the [ __ ] does blow
up at the end uh and he does shoot
himself in the face in order to kill the
tyler durden part of himself but he does
live yeah um so the implication being
that he's even though obviously he
couldn't stop project mayhem the [ __ ]
that he started he's now come to a place
where he understands that there has to
be like some kind of balance between the
things yeah now you got oh so you have
to
there's another an alternate
interpretation
if you noticed him
in his normal self trying to stop the
plan and every time he did that he
actually forwarded it more
well because in his tyler durden thing
he had basically
he said i'm gonna say this right you
know and him caring about [ __ ] tits all
right is what gave them the idea to
[ __ ] sacrifice their lives so you
must remember that oh not because now he
they added to the warrior mythos yeah of
that day that
dying in a selfless act which is that's
what the militaries are all about dying
in a selfish act gives you immortality
in the minds of the other cult members
it's kind of like it's religious it's
like you know
going up to heaven or returning to
valhalla that's basically what what it
is
so without him caring about it
the group probably wouldn't have worked
so no matter what he did he was helping
um yeah because well he didn't realize
that he was working at cross purposes to
himself because it was almost kind of
like like i said he
was essentially a split personality so
one was saying he was talking about out
both sides of his mouth without
realizing yeah because he thought that
he was a separate person another thing
is that nietzsche would say to not be in
that eternal struggle of trying to
achieve an amount of dominance would be
would not make would would be
to do what a lot of buddhists did which
is meant
would be to try to become above
something or to try to withdraw from the
conflicts of life and in the nichian
sense that makes you a loser the worst
kind of man
so in a way
um this idea of trying to stop this big
attack or trying to renormalize things
and make everybody friendly and normal
again would be
an abomination
from an ichian point of view and even
his lesser self
his lesser self was set up by his
superior self if that's what to
even when he tried to foil it it was set
up already that he actually just
improved it
and i think it's also taught about
which may be
like they're talking about the duality
of man that it's inescapable
you know i mean that's inescapable that
even if you're a loser in a way you're
kind of empowering winners even if it's
within yourself
that's that's how i interpreted it
and but that's nietzsche's and scope and
schopenhauer
and and and buddhism you know you're not
you're not moralizing in a normal sense
it's just what worked and what happened
and
he since he achieved the mission
that that
that that confirms everything that that
what's his name that that i guess you
could say the
his uh darker self it confirmed that it
won
you know
yeah he couldn't stop it
well yeah because you know
he didn't realize until right too late
now in that philosophy that victory is
only temporary
because in the nature of the universe
you're replaced just like everything
else it's a cycle
so he was probably replaced he probably
went to the lunatic asylum or went to
prison because the cops knew who he was
well yeah well the cops were already
beginning to suspect that he had
actually blown up his own apartment
which he had right uh even though he
didn't
realize it so they were closing in on
him i mean they called and said hey we
need you to come down here because they
had figured out that he had blown up his
own apartment yeah uh so
yeah yeah in real life
uh he's not gonna escape no it was like
a suicide attack a certain way it was
just uh
uh
him achieving dominance over what he saw
as an oppressive
enemy which were these those bags
that's that's what all it was and he was
ready to give his own life to get it
done that falls right into nietzsche
right underneath nietzsche says it's
better to die
um
believing and it's not better to die
fighting for what you believe in and go
down in a hail of bullets than it is to
live as a slave or a loser in the face
of an enemy so it's like a death before
dishonor kamikaze
mentality
that choosing life is failure in that in
that sense of the word in in in that
situation
a lot of stuff in this movie too about
fear of emasculation
um you know particularly with this
testicular cancer group you know with uh
you know they don't have any balls and
you know like meatloaf having [ __ ] tits
and him being like a woman blonde guy
too pretty had had to destroy somebody
who was i yeah and it destroys all the
beautiful there's a lot of that kind of
stuff in there and uh also a lot of homo
eroticism gotta say yep um which
probably not surprising because chuck
palahniuk the novelist is gay himself so
uh it's not it's not homoeroticism per
se
bromances well it's not super overt but
there are some scenes in there there's
undertones yeah there's definitely some
lines in there that could be definitely
be interpreted it's like sexual
hierarchy between dominance and who's
the [ __ ] and who's the man that type i
mean that whole scene with like where
where edward norton is in the bathroom
and the brad pitt is in the tub yeah and
then uh brad pitt saying something like
we're a generation of men raised by
women do we really think more women is
the answer to this right yeah uh you
know
masculinity right so it's kind of like
this whole so that's what i meant by
homer ryan and like i said there have
been whole papers written about this
movie in that context
daddy-ism yeah it's that yeah which that
pl that flows right into what i was
saying before about these nichian
warrior philosophies which that's ernst
rom and the sa
they were just like that well
they were they were the ones that
founded old nazi party they were [ __ ]
leather daddies
conveniently erased from history but
look it up ernst rome bad [ __ ]
world war one
he was a world war one um
hero all battle scarred and he was just
predatory
that was a
a men's rights organization is what they
called it and that was a euphemism for
leather daddies yeah yeah
uh the director david fincher which i
thought this was very interesting
he called fight club a coming-of-age
film like the graduate but for
gen x yeah
um and he says uh the character uh you
know the narrator who like i said is not
named
um
fincher says he's tried to do everything
he was taught to do tried to fit into
the world by becoming the thing he isn't
he cannot find happiness so he travels
on a path to enlightenment in which you
must kill his parents god and teacher
yeah so his parents are dead at the
beginning i guess he says like his mom
is dead and his dad like took off when
he was six or whatever killing god
morning yeah and then killing his
teacher in the end so you know
metaphorically killing brad pitt that
part of him yeah that uh that taught him
like his sensei or whatever
um and and david fincher argues that
that's how he uh had to complete his
self-actualization by killing his
teacher didn't wasn't there a nietzsche
quote about starring becoming a dragon
if you chase a dragon too long he'd come
or yeah or something i think they said
that yes there's a niche i don't
remember if it's in the movie but
somebody says something that equates to
that i think
in a movie that we saw recently and it
might have been in this movie because
sometimes we'll see two of them in a day
yeah i don't remember it being in this
movie but it might be i mean you know
what i mean we did we did actually have
the because this is actually the second
or third time i've seen this like i said
this is one of those great movies where
watching it a second time knowing the
twist yeah it's way way better because
now you can kind of see all the there's
like all these little easter eggs in
this too where you know uh you know the
first half of the movie which is very
like talking about how consumerist and
how everything is like taking over
everything
in the background
frame of like almost every shot is a
starbucks cup yeah and they just like
stick them in the back like all the time
because they're he's trying to like make
a statement about the like ubiquity of
like these massive brands and everything
like that so but he did it like in sort
of a subtle before i forget just so i
don't
so to answer anybody else's questions
but i was talking about
nietzsche was saying it's better to go
out and [ __ ] basically a kamikaze attack
than to live as a slave or to live in a
defeated state
some people might be like well what kind
of life is that that's you know how is
that life affirming well in this
thinking you're going to die anyway
you're going to die eventually from old
age
you might be 20 or 30 might be 40 you
might be only giving up 10 years of your
life
and this sacrifice is supposed to be
honored
by your cult it's a human sacrifice you
wrote and it's to allow other things to
live that's the idea you're getting rid
of something that's bad
something that's oppressive and when
it's gone it will allow other things to
rise up out of the [ __ ] morris of
life you know because that's the
nietzsche kind of looked at it's kind of
like the kind of like the force
uh out of star wars out of the [ __ ]
swamp of life great things sometimes
come you know and you have to allow it
to you have to allow these things to
come into being so the cycle can roll
forward
and that
we may or may not live in an afterlife
afterwards it doesn't matter
you know i think nietzsche would say we
probably don't
but maybe uh our soul or our energy
might be converted into something else
he would call the will
um
and that's this movie is about will it's
about willpower
the thing about it is that as i said i
think they because when it first came
out in 1999 and the studio executives
didn't really know how to market it and
so they said well we'll just focus on
the fighting because that's violence and
they know that'll bring in like a male
audience yeah even though interestingly
the original audience for it that they
pulled was about 60 40 male female um
mostly young obviously because this is
more of a young person's movie i suppose
back in 1999
but
that's what i meant though when i said
that even though they they focus very
much on the fighting and the violence
and that is a part of the movie that's
not really i mean they're not fighting
for anything they're just fighting
because they don't feel anything and
they need to feel something
and they're trying to learn to kind of
maybe tap back into their savagery or
tap back into a thing where
um you know they can get past their pain
or they can't they can be so they are
like no longer afraid of pain anymore
what they're talking about is they're
saying people who are normal consumers
live comfortable lives under capitalism
they don't suffer
they buy their way out of suffering
for the most part
um
and uh you get soft by doing that and
you get distant from nature
from from from the from the damn the
cycle of life and death i guess you
could say it's kind of insulating you
there's a pain pleasure principle in
people they move towards pleasure and
away from pain
and capitalism encourages that
so in his little training system he gets
them to fight to each other and if
you've ever been in a fight
your first fight you're kind of scared
of getting hit in the face you get hit
in the face and if you're not knocked
out immediately you realize it doesn't
really hurt
so your fear of the fight goes away as
you start fighting harder
i know whether i'm going to win or lose
the first time a dude hits me in the
face if i'm not knocked out immediately
then i know i'm probably gonna whip his
ass
because if he was any good he would have
knocked me out in a single blow
you know
and the fear of the pain goes away
because you're numb after the first
first hit hits you it's like shaking a
camera you might black out for a second
or see stars and then after that you
don't feel any pain at all or any fear
you just double triple quadruple down
into it
and that's getting into that animal
fight or flight response you go into
fight that's what this movie is talking
about they're developing that into
people to move away from pleasure and
towards pain you'll have strength and
you'll be able to sacrifice yourself
later on that and then you're getting
into the brotherhood of people who are
like that it's like you become a
different species of man that's what the
movie's talking about
well and i was gonna say too that it
doesn't even necessarily have to be
fighting but it's just like anything
that is
that makes you afraid yeah um that's why
even like if you have phobias and stuff
like that one of the things they try to
do is make you you know face that all
the time like do it so because the fear
of it is oftentimes like worse than the
actual thing well he'd go over and drive
into the oncoming lanes and the dudes in
the back seats and just tolerate it
because you're either going to die or
not you just resigned
yeah they're trying to overcome the fear
of death because the your death would be
inconsequential anyway you're going to
die you will die eventually anyway of
old age or disease
so what difference does it make they
don't have anything they're in a warrior
cult their whole identity is to build up
built to build up the the resistance to
fear and pain
to become almost kind of like superhuman
that's what they're doing
interestingly i found this kind of
interesting uh i don't think necessarily
brad pitt was the first choice for that
role uh i think it was supposed to be
what's that motherfucker's name uh
russell crowe yeah which
yeah maybe
i mean russell crowe was uh yeah yeah
he's [ __ ] crazy that probably would
have worked but on the phones that
played people throw throw phone throwing
[ __ ]
but honestly i have him throw a phone at
me
like crow crow tell the phone bro throw
the phone bro you probably get sick of
everybody asking yeah probably probably
i ain't throwing a [ __ ] phone at you
you know
although if you asked him enough times
he probably probably get mad at it [ __ ]
you you know throw the phone yeah
yeah yeah it well i think it would have
been a different movie honestly though i
think i'm i'm glad they went with brad
pitt because honestly this is
this is one of my favorite performances
of his if not my favorite performances
he's great in this yeah he's great in
him he's a perfect match for it he's
very slick good looking real cut and he
just seems like a lunatic and yeah and
then there's like he also did good and
was it 12 monkeys he did get a good yeah
similar to that kind of guy a little
more held together yeah i mean twelve
monkeys he was like
but yeah um yeah it's a great role uh he
did a great job in it
but um
you have to remember you're watching
this [ __ ] you they're doing [ __ ] you're
like why are they why are they risking
so much over so little this is a
spiritual journey for them they're
reaching what
some buddhists would probably call
enlightened indifference
to where
they know that they could die but
they're just letting it go
so what
it doesn't matter if we live or die
which that's what you have you have to
be like that to be a damn kamikaze which
is basically what we're talking about
being a kamikaze
certain advantages to being a kamikaze
you can't threaten the kamikaze they
tried to threaten this dude at his job
and he out kamikazed the [ __ ] boss
and then he boss was his [ __ ] had to
pay him for the rest of his life
yeah so which again was kind of was kind
of like tied back into what i was saying
before about you know critiquing the
consumers culture but then becoming that
because at the end of the film the fight
clubs have become quote unquote
franchise and the fact that he
essentially bribed his boss or
terrorized his boss into just giving him
checks for not showing up yeah uh he's
like oh we now have corporate
sponsorship yeah so
that didn't weaken it that strengthened
it
because now they were everywhere he had
a massive army
after that that's how he ended up
finding out that he was actually tyler
dirty because he was going looking for
tyler durden who
abandoned him just like his dad did they
were kind of like playing with that and
then people were like recognizing him
and calling him by that name and he
didn't know what the [ __ ] was people
like to pretend that they can achieve
moral superiority over over an
oppressive force ah no the reason why
the force is oppressing you is because
it's better than you
it's using techniques and it has
strengths that you don't have and it's
using those against you the only way to
beat it is to get those same strengths
and take it away
so you are the one with the swords and
the axes and the banks and the money and
that's what he did
you can't do it any other way
and that's that's nietzsche too
stop trying to moralize the [ __ ] just
use what works the reason why you're
being oppressed because there's an enemy
using something against you that works
and that's what you need that's the tool
that you need
same thing as with conventional armies
if you live in a regular country they
tell you this is all this asymmetrical
warfare that's all terrorism
well that's what they do though we hire
terrorists to send them to other
countries all right uh
things that conventional forces that i
did when i was in the army things like
wearing camouflage
back in the 1700s that'd be considered
terrorism you'd have to you're supposed
to wear a red suit or a blue suit or
something white that you could aim at
you could see because it's not fair to
hide only a coward would hide
so everything all modern forms of
warfare are terrorism from the point of
view of the generation of warfare that
came before it
and that's what they did that's what
this movie's also talking about that too
um i will note too that uh the author of
the novel chuck palaniuk who is actually
like i've actually uh really liked a lot
of his uh books i liked haunted i liked
lullaby uh this one's great too like i
said this first one um and interestingly
like i said the the ending is different
but chuck palaniuk really really liked
this movie adaptation he thought it was
[ __ ] great now one thing that david
fincher did say though is that one of
the reasons he changed well it
changed the ending sort of but he said
that he thought that in the book
um it was too uh
he said
that uh the novel was too quote unquote
infatuated with tyler and uh his quote
was i wanted people to love tyler but i
also wanted them to be okay with his
vanquishing that's what he said about
the end of the movie and maybe why he
changed it i haven't read the book in a
long time so i can't remember exactly
what happened at the end but i do
remember that the narrator did end up in
an insane asylum so it wasn't quite
i don't know if i'd call the movie like
the end of the movie like a happy ending
that's or an uplifting ending i guess it
depends on your perspective on it like
how you look at it he won but at a heavy
price
yeah and and like i said he did seem to
achieve some kind of balance or some
kind of peace with himself
um you know by sort of like into
vanquishing his teacher if you want to
call it that way or like i said there's
a lot of different interpretations of it
well when the banks fell it reduced not
only him to zero everybody else in the
world was zero
remember yeah because all the debts were
forgiven
so everybody was starting out equally
yeah so his self-sacrifice actually
equalized a lot of other you know
millions of other people so his his
sacrifice didn't happen in vain yeah so
it's the it's the thinking of the
broader picture of the movie
of his personal war of liberation
now
is the liberation permanent no
it's part of a cycle the the the
competition restarts again the rich
people start to arise then they be then
they go down the same path he he went
down except in the economic realm and
then they become rich people and
oppressive again because they own banks
and corporations
or banks and corporations start you know
becoming oppressive and governments
it's just part of the cycle i mean the
more i think about this movie the more
i'm just kind of like well you can't win
so you might you can't win you might as
well just kind of like chill out and yep
like what you like and just try to eek
some happiness out of life because you
can't [ __ ] win no
no because it's a cycle yeah no matter
what you do it's just gonna end up in
this yeah it'll end up exactly where
it's working that sounds depressing but
not really it's not no it frees you
yeah
yeah now you do not have moral impetus
to try to correct things
uh in the way it may be like christian
morality would tell you to do it because
you could correct it but then it
wouldn't be corrected for long it would
just go back to the way it was it
reverts to the mean yeah you know you
can only do things on a small scale
between people that you know
you might be helped that person you
might help people in your family you
might go
help people in your local community but
you can't really
do it on a global scale you know doesn't
work that way everybody has different
desires that conflict with that you help
that person well [ __ ] that person might
be an enemy of somebody else they don't
want you helping their enemy it's that
kind of and honestly most people's
resources are pretty limited it's not
like you know i'm not a billionaire i
couldn't like you know feed a whole
country of people if i wanted to you
know what i'm saying yeah so this movie
here
on the tom ross scale
i'll put this as a masterpiece up there
very similar to me
uh with uh the art of self defense
i thought you would you would uh find
that comparison yeah very similar
because i was kind of thinking that
we're watching it because like i said i
was amazed you had never seen it yeah um
because i mean this is such a [ __ ]
classic and like i said it's just it's
one of those ones that it just it seemed
like it came out maybe a little too
early maybe people weren't ready for it
or they didn't really know what to make
of it at the time but then over time now
it's just kind of like everybody yeah i
feel like everybody in the world has
seen this [ __ ] book fight club is the
alphas the alpha's vision
of the problems of life and reality
and then
art of self-defense is more kind of like
from the beta's point of view
but they're equally true a lot of things
we just like obi-wan said many of the
things we believe upon believe in depend
upon a certain point of view
but both those movies are essentially
true from but they're from two different
viewpoints i like them both yeah and the
dude that wrote art of self-defense he's
beta you know what i mean uh but he was
right
very right about a lot of that stuff
you know the warrior cultism
that a lot of it is [ __ ] fake
[Laughter]
the fake in a certain way fake that
there was a lot of cheating involved
and it wasn't it wasn't as natural as
you think uh it can go both ways you
know yeah it could go both ways yeah
so yeah so like i said pretty much
everybody watching this i'm sure you
guys have seen fight club what did you
guys think of it what is your
interpretation of it please tell me down
in the comments let's have a discussion
i love this movie i mean
i have yet to see a david fincher movie
that i didn't like except maybe alien
three but that was his first one give
him a break uh but everything else that
i've seen of his is just
i mean he is just a masterful filmmaker
every frame of this yeah is just in
service to i didn't say anything about
the greater theme the way it looks is
great it's got a great [ __ ] score
uh the edit is fantastic it's it's a
great piece of cinema
philosophically
it's it's instructional value it's
educational value
one of the best movies ever made
one of the best movies ever made in
terms of
what you can learn from it
so you know i'm glad that uh that you
finally got to see this oh yeah like i
said i'm surprised one of the best
movies ever
yeah okay well that's awesome that i'd
say top five i know i mean i figured you
were gonna like it yeah um just because
i hadn't seen it a long time but i
remembered enough about it that i said
oh he'll probably love this movie and
i'm amazed that he hasn't seen it yet
i'm not talking about action movies you
know predator alien
i'm just talking about in terms of just
movie and what you can learn from
this one man
in the top five i mean any movie that
inspires this much debate and you know
kind of
that has like whole papers written about
it i mean you know you can't really
argue with that can't you yeah right
there with them apocalypse now
everything you know just
yeah
now that you mention it yeah
yeah so uh all right fight club you guys
uh
so
that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we will see you guys on
the next one bye